I am very happy today because we have an
incredible paper here get this it helps
us transform into virtual characters and
transfer our movements to them wow but
it gets better we can even control
virtual characters with different
morphology than our bodies we can be a
tiny little mouse or a dinosaur and wait
it gets even better all this from a
three Point input not full body this is
not motion capture where an entire
bodysuit is used and we know the
movement of every body part no sir what
we know here is so much more challenging
just the movement of the VR headset and
two controllers nothing else that is
really tough and to me it sounds
absolutely impossible so is it
impossible well almost
let's see if this paper can pull it off
dear fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr
car first for a training step it uses
motion capture data to learn which human
joints match the virtual characters
joints for training unfortunately this
does not work great but wait don't
despair not All Is Lost why is that well
we can now create a reinforcement
learning agent which can lean on this
jerky animation and then learn to
control it properly here wo this looks
so much better loving it and note that
at this step we can throw away all the
motion capture data and we only need the
headset and two controllers so far so
good so are we done well we are not done
yet not even close we also need a little
trickery for dealing with the head
orientation or otherwise we will look
like this and it gets even worse due to
the heavy head of the mouse character
even this can happen ouch but after this
additional step look M much better
additionally to add more realism we can
even decide how we wish to control the
tail of the dinosaur as well loving it
so are we done now well we are still not
done yet the paper also proposes
enriching the training data with
additional information for the AI to
learn and then throwing this data away
but come on if we don't do that what's
the worst that can happen well this this
can happen ouch but putting this all
together hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars and look it finally works now
we have have an absolutely miraculous
algorithm that can perform these
movements across different morphologies
with different character types it does
it in an energy efficient way so that we
get relatively elegant smooth movements
and not those jerky ones excellent but
wait a second are you thinking what I am
thinking remember it has information
from the headset and the controllers
does that mean that yes that's exactly
what it means it has no lower body
information whatsoever and yet it can
still reconstruct all of these movements
really well wow that is crazy and it
gets better larger and smaller
characters will be moved around
differently you just walk around in your
own pace but for them depending on their
size more or maybe fewer TP Tabs are
required and advanced movements are also
possible staggering balancing you name
it well for smaller more agile
characters that is and we can even try
our dancing moves in this case they are
perhaps a little inapt but in a very
cute way and not just movement but
acting can be done so good loving it and
yes it gets even even better if that is
at all possible I have found three more
mindblowing things about this paper one
it has been trained on just one machine
with one consumer graphics card and not
even a high-end one the training took 24
hours and this step only has to be done
once and then we can use it in real time
for as long as we wish two so how much
training data is required for the this
get this only 4 hours it looks at 4
hours of footage from a bunch of humans
and then it generalizes the movement to
new people and three what you are about
to see now is the reason two minute
papers exists look this paper has been
seen by less than a 100 people such an
amazing work and I am worried that if we
don't talk about it here almost no one
will talk about it so if you fellow
Scholars would help me spread the word
of this amazing AI SL computer graphics
paper that would be amazing thank you
now don't forget this technique is still
not completely automatic I noted earlier
that some of the joints of the human are
mapped to the new character so you can't
just drop in a completely new character
without some additional work however in
return vastly different morphologies
work I would estimate that not a great
deal of work has to be done per
character but it still requires a bit of
work and expertise and I bet that just
one more paper down the line and we will
be able to do this automatically just
imagine a world where we can all become
virtual characters where we can play
together and the way we move is
translated by an algorithm to feel like
we are really any creature we want even
if they have have a completely different
morphology big head small head floppy
ears or a tail anything you can imagine
and I am absolutely Blown Away by the
fact that it may not even need to track
our lower body for that only the threep
point input head and hands and don't
forget the differences between these
models are huge there are vast
variations in weight 25x difference
between the lightest and heaviest
character tail joints may or may not
exist and even if they do there is a
different amount of joints same with the
ear joints and the amount of torque they
can produce is also subject to a great
deal of variation and having a modern
algorithm that can translate all of our
motions to these characters is
absolutely
incredible wow what a time to be alive
if you you're looking for inexpensive
Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now offers the
best prices in the world for GPU Cloud
compute no commitments or negotiation
required just sign up and launch an
instance and hold on to your papers
because with the Lambda GPU Cloud you
can now get on demand h100 instances for
just1 199 per hour yes1 199 and the they
are one of the first Cloud providers to
offer publicly available on demand h100
accs did I mention they also offer
persistent storage so join researchers
at organizations like apple MIT and
Caltech in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today